[Music]
I go here and what do you you want to
get what do you want to do okay got it
so we'll you go we'll pass open and
grab here this russing tie right here
you have the wrist and you have the
elbow and of course you
have go
I do my move I come around he's doing
his move you see and here's your
yel right there so he he's coming this
way you round it and then you have that
[Music]
oh for
so as you're training this don't push
this out here you just enter okay also
you're going into the Russian tie even
more
your counter is very short boom right
there keep contact with him Bo
Bo elbows always
[Music]
inside if your partner can't do it or
you need to have do x pot this way